[Musique]
on dit qu'il est le plus grand château
en bois rond au monde son majestueux
hall son foyer et sa cheminée de 20
mètres de hauteur font sa signature au
fil des années en plus d'être un centre
de villégiature prisé le château
montebello a accueilli des invités de
marque
mais dans ce prestigieux hôtel il y a
les événements que vous connaissez est
ce que vous ignorez
potentiellement il y avait des absents
d'amiante qui circulent potentiellement
il avait déjà des clients de l'hôtel qui
circulent elles ici puis jouer qui avait
plusieurs fnac qui étaient restées
ouvertes dans les leurs à rénovation
ici comme ailleurs au québec
nous avons découvert que dans plusieurs
chantiers des travaux de désamiantage
sont mal réalisés et respirer de la
poussière d'amiante peut vous tuer et je
trouve cette source
je trouve trop sonore qu'on accepte
comme ça c'était carrément illégales
quand le château montebello a voulu
faire bonheur en 2018
c'est un défi qui attendait les
travailleurs dans cet hôtel au charme
rustique l'anc
on voit que ces neuf tout a été refait
pour accéder à la plomberie les
travailleurs du chantier au pôle choix
de retirer les vieux plancher limon
aussi toutes les chambres doivent être
rénovés des travaux de plus de 15
millions de dollars une facture salée
notamment parce que derrière ces bio se
cachent de l'amiante
l'entrepreneur général qui obtient le
contrat est donc avisés des mesures
sévères de sécurité qu'il aura à prendre
pour désamianter avant la rénovation
c'est ce qu'exige la loi au québec en
fait l'amiante on pourrait le qualifier
et toutes les formes d'amiante d'un
cancer aux gens une puissance parce que
ça prend pas nécessairement de très
grande exposition commence à avoir un
risque de cancer il faut mettre en place
à ce moment beaucoup de mécanismes de
protection pour les travailleurs qui
sont présents et où si la population que
photo mais on commence dans les travaux
les travailleurs qui représente marque
la framboise et plombiers notamment
s'aperçoivent qu'il y a un problème il y
avait des certaines personnes qui
avaient des masques qui faisait le qui
joue avec l'amiante mais la personne aux
côtés cinq pieds bots protection voici à
quoi ressemble un désamiantage
sécuritaire dans cette vidéo les
travailleurs porte un habit étanche et
un masque complet la zone de travaux est
complètement scellé une zone de
décontamination assure aussi que les
travailleurs ne charrie pas de matières
dangereuses à l'extérieur mais ce n'est
pas ce qui s'est passé
le syndicat a des photos qui montrent
des travailleurs qui enlève de l'amiante
en tee shirt
les morceaux d'amiante friable à
découvert sur tous les planchers en
dehors de la zone c les sont couverts de
poussière
ça c'était considéré comme propre mais
sur les photos c'est ici qu'on voit la
poussière
donc s'il ya de la poussière si puis
consorts marchés à l'extérieur puis je
voyais est que la majorité des fenêtres
dans une des ailes en construction et un
majeur terme est ouverte
et combien de travailleurs en tout à
votre avis ont pu être exposés un peu
plus de 30 travailleurs 150 km à l'est
quelques années plus tôt aux abords du
canal lachine à montréal l'événement
de 2005 à 2015
stewart macadam habiter ce vieil
immeuble s'élancer l'édifice de la
compagnie craint construit en 1920 ses
propriétaires philippe et marc hoffmann
l'ont embauché comme gestionnaire
pendant cette période ils constatent la
présence de nombreux tuyaux isolé à
l'amiante
quand les propriétaires font faire des
travaux sous sol leurs employés sont
massivement exposés selon stewart
macadam j'ai commencé à documenter la
situation j'étais inquiet de ce qui se
passait move toute la tuyauterie du
sous-sol était en train d'être enlevé de
tels travaux génèrent de grandes
quantités de poussières d'amiante
stewards macadam a récupéré des résidus
sur le chantait en 2015
nous l'avons accompagné pour qu'ils les
fassent analysés en laboratoire
la morphologie et claire et les couleurs
aussi confirme que c'est du chrysotile
aucun doute il s'agit bien d'amiante
on a retrouvé 10 à 25% damian de type
chrysotile ce qui représente au minimum
100 fois plus que la limite permise au
québec y toi est manipulé par un expert
qui a des normes très strictes à suivre
pour les manipuler en toute sécurité
mais à l'édifice green stewart mcardle
constate que les travailleurs n'ont
aucune idée des conséquences de ce
qu'ils font c'est le cas de john celli
david schultz originaire de lituanie
à l'époque ils ignorent ce qu'est
l'amiante et se contente de faire ce
qu'on lui demande
comme immigrants j'avais peur de perdre
cet emploi alors je continuer d' enlever
l'amiante
il quitte régulièrement l'édifice avec
ses vêtements complètement recouvert
d'amiante
contrairement au règlement il expose non
seulement les passagers d'autobus et de
métro
sa famille aussi vous revenez à la
maison et vos enfants étaient là et vous
les prenez dans vos bras
oui oui je les soulever ils prenaient
dans mes bras je ne l'avais pas vue de
la journée vous ne saviez pas que
c'était de l'amiante
non je ne savais rien quand on est
exposé à l'amiante on tombe pas malade
le lendemain sapera des fois jusqu'à 40
ans avant que la maladie se développe
stewart macadam a réuni certains
travailleurs et résidents de l'immeuble
pour qu'ils obtiennent des informations
de l'association des victimes d'amiante
du québec pour l'exposition la hms york
les scientifiques n'ont pas encore
réussi à identifier ont beau de tels
niveaux pas de danger dans la salle
c'est l'incrédulité et la colère
saviez pas tant que ça qui avait autant
damian duff seulement pour le gérant
projets qui étaient là c'est simplement
si tu ta job fais ce que je te demande
j'ai énormément de frustration envers le
propriétaire du building qui savait très
bien que j'habitais là avec un enfant
mon chien ma petite amie qui n'ont
jamais qui le temps demain informé de la
situation
tous ceux qui ont été potentiellement
exposées devraient être notifiés point à
la ligne
[Musique]
mcadam alerté les autorités à l'époque
la commission de la construction est
intervenu pour l'embauché de
travailleurs non qualifiés les kaufmann
ont dû verser 270 mille dollars en
salaires impayés selon nos informations
la commission de la construction a aussi
signalé la présence potentielle
d'amiante à la cnss t qui nous a
confirmé qu'il y avait une plaie tu es
une visite mais qu'aucun arrêt des
travaux n'a été fait les mecs me fait ça
me frustre vraiment selon moi ils ne
veulent pas que les gens sachent
des chantiers d'amiante mal géré
catherine la palme en a vu plusieurs
particulièrement dans la rénovation
résidentielle où elle oeuvre comme
menuisier
d'après moi je pense que 75 % des
entrepreneurs qui font pas dans les
règles de l'art le désamiantage dans
toutes les résidences construites avant
l'amiante peut se trouver dans le plâtre
les tuiles les bardeaux autour des
tuyaux mais sur la douzaine de chantiers
de montréal où elle a travaillé au cours
des deux dernières années
catherine constate que peu de gens
semblent s'en préoccuper lorsqu ils
démolissent il ya comme deux mondes en
fait c'est le monde de l'école ce qu'ils
disent qu'il faut que tu fasses puis le
monde la construction qui comme une
banalisation au total de ce qui peut se
trouver dans les murs film
elle a finalement osé dénoncer la
présence d'amiante sur chantier ça me
choque de voir des entrepreneurs qui
font ça aussi en 2018 quand elle appelle
la cnss t on lui parle d'une
intervention dès le lendemain
mais ce n'est pas ce qui se produit il
ya de la poussière on a de la misère à
se voir d'une pièce à l'autre d'une
pièce d'un bout d'une pièce à l'autre et
tutsi qui a probablement de l'amiante
lambda ben oui c'est ça ça prendra
finalement deux jours avant que l'arrêt
du chantier soit ordonnée mais j'étais
vraiment choquée que j'ai rappelé à ses
nécessités comme un sac et personnes qui
avaient passé n'avait pas vraiment
d'explication de façon générale la
rapidité d'intervention on devrait
pourtant compté mais on veut intervenir
le plus tôt possible parce que sinon les
journées vont s'accumuler où les jours
deviennent des semaines et des semaines
d'entraînement et le long commence à
parler d'un risque de vie significatif
au château montebello aussi
l'inspectrice se fait attendre
bâle ii d'environ une semaine une
semaine et demie où ce que ça se passe
les travailleurs ils lèvent le drapeau y
et on veut faire quelque chose on veut
intervenir puis on est on sait qu'on n'a
pas su sport la cnss
dans ce cas il faudra une quinzaine de
plaintes et 3 visite de l'inspectrice
avant que le chantier ne soit suspendu
pourtant le rapport indique clairement
que des matériaux contenant de l'amiante
sont dans un état friable que la
poussière peut se retrouver ce plus d'un
étage et que les travailleurs sur les
lieux ne sont pas protégés avec un
appareil de protection respiratoire
adéquat l'entrepreneur fautif marque la
verdure affirme malgré tout avoir bien
fait son travail et soutient que les
clients de l'hôtel n'ont pas pu être
exposés il aurait pu monter un dossier
solide avec le château montebello pour
faire appliquer des sanctions pénales
s'apprête à faire on semble bien loin de
la politique de tolérance zéro pourtant
clairement affiché sur le site de la
cnss t
à votre connaissance est ce que
l'entrepreneur et où le château ont reçu
un constat d'infraction une amende
quelque chose une réprimande pas du tout
une petite tape ses doigts de retour à
montréal les copains n'ont pas voulu
accorder d'entrevue au téléphone ils
disent qu'ils n'ont appris la présence
d'amiante que lors de la visite de la
cnss t en mai 2015 qu'ils ont par la
suite fait des amiantés par une
entreprise spécialisée
mais souvenez-vous de la vidéo quand
vous a montré plutôt elle a été tourné
presque deux semaines avant le passage
de l'inspectrice
il y à de l'amiante bien visible et
exposé autour du réservoir
un travailleur va jusqu à le manipuler
sans l'équipement nécessaire voici le
même réservoir vue d'un autre angle une
dizaine de jours plus tard
tout juste avant la visite de
l'inspectrice tous leurs vêtements
d'amiante a été enlevé philippe kaufmann
ne reconnaît pas ces images ne nous ont
même pas donné de masques au début mais
ça au couteau et on enlevait sa morceau
par morceau
et comme c'était haut dans les airs la
poussière tombait sur new world kaufmann
ne nous ont rien dit à ce sujet
cinq ans plus tard stewart macadam
talonne toujours la csst pour qu'elle
fasse un suivi auprès des personnes
exposées
moi je vous croyez d'abord qui était
leur qui a travaillé lors l'employeur
doit informer qu'à travers ce qu'elle
vénérait travaux pour l'amiante mais
infi de moi j'ai plus de contrôle aux
tourments devrait obliger la commission
d'instaurer une nouvelle pratique de
registre d'exposition l'amiante
lorsque le travail est exposé sans
protection en attendant que le
gouvernement agisse l'association des
victimes d'amiante essaie d'informer et
de répertorier les personnes qui ont
respiré de la poussière d'amiante
ce crédit cet écrit ça reste à vie comme
document pour documenter votre
exposition parce qu'on ne saura que dans
10 20 30 ans court guide victime
pourrait avoir fait les chantiers où les
règles n'ont pas été suivis par tous les
travailleurs le temps fait la démo si m6
des ventilateurs ce qu'il garoche à
l'extérieur clan les arches les voisins
qui à roche des fois juste du james bond
et fois de l'amiante aussi ça se fait ça
continue le monde
c'est notamment pour cette raison que la
ville de westmount a décidé de prendre
les grands moyens et résidents doivent
prouver à la ville qu'ils ont fait un
test pour savoir s'il ya de l'amiante
dans leur propriété
avant d'entreprendre des rénovations
vous fait carrément ne pas émettre de
permis tant que document sion peu de
choix c'est 60 entre le piano et un
grand nombre des résidences de wesmount
contiennent la substance cancérogène ses
propres et moitié moitié des écoles où
ce qui est la mienne
parce qu'une fois que les choses
tournent mal sur un chantier personne ne
semble vouloir informer les victimes
potentielles
les gestionnaires ne veulent même pas
accordé d'entrevue
en effet d'abord on veut pas le voir ma
part je ne t'ai jamais quelque chose
qu'on avait voulu mettre là bas le
propriétaire du château montebello le
groupe chinois evergreen a lui aussi
refusé de répondre à nos questions et
des questions il risque d'y en avoir
encore parce que deux autres ailes du
château montebello doivent être rénovés
en 2020
[Musique]